hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ich bin grad mitten in der arbeit
und zwar mache ich trat mit samira
einfach fotos für unser kochbuch und ich
hab gerade eben noch einen anruf
bekommen vom ard und zwar wird mich
nächste woche die liebe eben vom
haushaltsscheck team vom ard besuchen
und wenn sie herkommt dreht sich bei uns
alles ums thema backofen und ganz
besonders uns reinigen und jetzt wollte
ich euch mal fragen oder beziehungsweise
eure hilfe bitten
vielleicht habt ihr irgendwie
haushaltstipps oder irgendwelche tipps
von der oma die diese euch gegeben hat
wir bekommen am besten den backofen
wieder sauber oder ein backblech was
macht ihr wenn ihr zum beispiel ganz
viele fettspritzer im backofen habt das
kennt man ja auch das mal essensreste
runterfallen und die einbrennen
was ihr den backofen haupt saurer oder
kauft ihr euch jedes mal neu ist auch
ganz witzig auf jeden fall wird es mich
interessieren was ihr dafür tipps habt
und für tricks habt und ihr könnt ihr
mir einfach mal zu schicken
ihr könnt mir übrigens auch schreiben
oder auch einen video schicken im foto
schicken was ihr zum beispiel mal
richtig skurril ist mit eurem backofen
gemacht habt also man kann ja nicht nur
zum backen benutzen der murat zum
beispiel ist ganz coole geschichte der
den backofen mal benutzt und sein handy
zu trocknen und zwar weil das vorher
also fragt mich bitte nicht wie und
warum aber es war vorher auf die
toilette rhein gesehen die toilette
reingefahren und dann noch ein bisschen
funktioniert war aber leider nass und er
wollte natürlich trocknen weil er gehört
habt dann funktioniert wieder
und weil er einfach zu wenig zeit hatte
hatte einfach im backofen benutzt danach
was hier natürlich ganz kaputt also
bitte nicht nachmachen aber vielleicht
habt ihr auch solche geschichten wo er
etwas sagt ihr habt den backofen einfach
mal zweckentfremdet und was ganz
skurrile ist damit gemacht
auf jeden fall würde ich mich freuen
wenn ihr da ein paar tipps für mich hat
besonders zum reinigen irgendwelche
haushaltstipps dann könnt ihr mir gern
ein kurzes handy videos schicken gerne
auch fotos schicken oder einfach als
kommentar unter dieses video drunter
schreiben und ich freue mich schon ganz
arg auf eure rückmeldungen und ich sag
euch auf jeden fall bescheid wann die
sendung haushaltsscheck im ard läuft
freue mich schon über eure rückmeldungen
und morgen gibt es wieder ein ganz neues
video von mir mit einem richtig leckeren
rezept schaltet auf jeden fall ein
und ich freue mich schon bis dann
tschüss